being that he got fined 60,000 that pie
was like five six of his game chicks I
don't say and that's been I will get
sixteen game chess crazy onyx up Evan
how you doing chillin oh and the Emma
Smith Jersey got the bus down all got
the chain on so fear of God yeah I'm
incorrect yeah that's right the best bit
I've seen from all the adders and a
pulled up to the pool okay I'm feeling
that one man okay I'm good
you've been playing pool with huh I love
it yeah I love you what you got okay
okay strike hey CJ a lot of players get
fine yeah well if I'm the league from
the own team do you have any memorable
fine stories yeah I have when I had one
big fire story it was 2010 we didn't
know coming down here playing about you
know losing your official real cool Co
so he let a few guys they whatever lost
the after alone I think I had a big game
against yeah so we in we end up standing
you know he was like long back - by
meeting time so on Mondays and again we
used to meet probably like 12 o'clock
was me both skate finish you know Kenny
Britt Ryan will turn and went down to
the Fountainbleu all booked room stayed
chill chilled out or whatever and after
that we went to live and then what was
it like but it was crazy little friend
it was nice so we all plan to get back
to Nashville by 11 up top get off the
plane drive straight through straight to
work be there by 12 so Bo was close to
Vince you know so he and not waking up
yeah I guess he couldn't find us what I
was so you know they was in fear and
finally being late so they here to the
airport so I am I gonna contact me I
wake
it's not jumping arm taxi I rushed to
the airport or whatever but the whole
time I'm on the way
I'm Carly I'm Carly Ryan he's not
answering his own ten minutes away from
airport he finally asks I'm like we yeah
we finna get ready so he like brother
please don't let him leave you don't
leave I say Brian got my try I'm gonna
do my best my time I get there
we already on the runway I'm gonna jet
on the runway so I get down five per
taxi panel the jet from where I met at
the gate is probably like honey yards
away so I just I jump right in and I'm
just run so I got there I'm lining in
honey yards and I made it mister for 240
is running across time where the hell is
run by the time he pull up we take
enough damn we've taken our fee Missy
yeah he missed the flight you know
anytime you taking a private you get to
get there when you want but once y'all
load up
it's a certain time they gotta they
gotta take off so here not miss the
flight booking the flight with regular
airport is flight end up getting counsel
so when this flight get counsel hearing
up taint coming that whole day so he
missed a whole day and hardworking and
unfair all the fibers on Wednesday so
you get your Monday you work out to that
called a Wednesday Friday so all of you
walk in the locker room when we see our
envelope so when you see that certain
envelope in your locker you know it is
so we see what each of us got five like
20,000 and he got fined like sixty
pounds so go talk to the head coach he
like yeah y'all ain't make it back on
fire so y'all along got fun cuz when
your teammates I mean and make it back
at all that's the second year the league
how you doing when the gods on his
rookie contract goes to 60 racks like
that man is crazy because I just know
how the money situation isn't enough
family when you first come in you don't
make don't make a lot of money don't
make a lot of money like that so being
that he got five sixty thousand that
part it was like five six of his game
chips I don't say that's being like we
only get 16 game chess it was crazy
yeah we had a good time but it won't
that money you gonna scratch you nicely
you know I could do a little some thanks
for kicking it with us subscribe to be
our to check out more dope videos like
this one